we begin with that breaking news out of
sedan where the military has arrested
several civilian ministers and officials
protest leaders are calling on people to
take to the streets and resist what they
say could be a military coup tension has
been rising for weeks between military
and civilian factions sharing power in a
fragile transitional government that was
supposed to lead sudan to elections
after long-time leader omar al-bashir
was pushed from power in 2019 well heber
morgan joins us on the phone now from
kartum heber so a fast-moving developing
story what more have you been hearing
now about the arrests and and what the
military's been doing on the streets
well to know more about who is arrested
and very rare about it's very hard
because of the internet uh shut down
that because the government has imposed
as well as the restricted phone access
it's very hard to make calls near
impossible actually to recall uh on
landlines around horton uh because of
the restrictions that has been imposed
but we have been going around uh parts
of hot summer we've been able to see
people lighting up tires many parts of
khakim you can see black smoke from the
tires rising and that's in resistance to
the latest developments we've also seen
vehicles blocking all the bridges and
roads leading to the city of khartoum
that's where the presidential palace is
that's where the prime minister's office
is and that's where most government
institutions is so it's obvious that
there are fast developments that are
happening which many people here are now
regarding as a coup especially because
the guiding principle the guiding
document that's guiding this transaction
government is the constitutional
declaration the power sharing agreement
that was signed between the military and
civilians in august 2019 and it makes it
very clear that should the military move
or should any side move uh to make
changes in the makeup of the
transitional government without uh the
agreement of the other then that is
considered a coup now political
political parties have called on their
uh supporters to take to the streets and
that's what's happening although they
are dispersed around the three cities of
the capital cartoon because of the
shutdown on uh because of the
restrictions of access to bridges and
roads leading to hatsune but in many
parts of qatar
and and uh north people are burning
tires people are taking to the streets
we still don't know where the prime
minister abu muhammadu is but we know
that his uh his cabinet minister khalid
ahmed has been arrested we also know
that the minister of industry has been
arrested at the minister of information
as well now it's not clear how far this
group goes it's not clear how many
ministers have been arrested since the
internet until the communication
shutdown has imposed but people on the
streets are really uh upset we you can
hear them chanting you can see the tires
that they're burning you can see the
black smoke rising and they're saying
that this is a revolution that started
in 2018 obviously far from over if the
military is not willing to hand over
power to civilian rule yeah as we're
talking to you we're seeing some of the
latest pictures on our screens of those
protests on the street fires uh being
set what about state media heber and are
we expecting any kind of statement from
the military i mean they've been pretty
conspicuous by their silence
yes indeed now a state media is it to
issue any kind of statement to even give
an announcement that there is a
statement expected uh from
any government official at all the
minister of information who's the
government spokesperson is obviously
under arrest so he will not be able to
give that statement but we
we're yet to hear for uh any statement
from the military from uh the prime
minister
from anyone in his uh press office now
this is a very stark contradiction to
when an attempted school happened on the
21st of september just last month when
the state media immediately issued a red
banner saying that there is an attempt
to prove that the military is working to
contain it and a few hours later it cut
a statement by the press uh adviser of
the head of the sovereignty council
who's also the commander-in-chief of the
military now uh if you when you compare
it to that the state media has been
conspicuously silenced and it is to
issue a statement the army also has been
very silent uh now they've been accused
of backing this uh sitting in front of
the presidential palace that has been
going on for over a week
because people uh part of the ffc some
forces some groups in the forces of
freedom and change coalition that's the
coalition that led anti-government
protests against president bashir has
been demanding that the military take
over and dissolve the cabinet they say
that the forces of freedom and change
coalition is no longer representative of
all the groups that took part in the
revolution and has been hijacked by a
few political parties and therefore
needs reforms again when you go back to
the constitutional declaration the
military does not have the authority to
reform the forces of freedom and change
coalition that's something that has to
do with the coalition itself that the
military should not intervene in and
that's something that the uh advisor
this is the special envoy the u.s
special envoy to the horn of africa
yesterday his meeting with the cabinet
ministers and with the um head of the
sovereignty council stress on that the
civilians should be able to uh deal with
their issues and that there should be uh
and uh people should stick to the
constitutional declaration that was
signed between the two sides to ensure
that that's transition continues uh as
we're talking to you we're getting
updates uh about the situation um in
cartoon we're hearing that the airport
has been closed a few minutes ago we
heard that the military had sent
reinforcements to the airport uh so
clearly uh now the airport uh has been
closed in terms of the broader political
landscape heber let's just remind our
international viewers um uh that
relations have been soured between the
military and civilians now uh for some
time how fragile is the transitional
government and and why is there such
tension uh between the generals and the
civilian leaders
now relationship has been very fragile
since the attempted coup between um
between the civilians and the military
last month but it has it has simply
heightened for months now prime minister
abdullah has been calling on the
security sector to reform itself while
the security in the military sector has
been calling on the forces of freedom
and change coalition uh to reform itself
both to blame each other for the lack of
uh uh progress to incident transition
both blame each other for the political
uh uh uh for the slow political
development of the country the slow
economic growth
with the military saying that uh prime
minister hamduk and his cabinet have not
been able to give concrete solutions to
the economic crisis that support the
protest in uh december 2018. so uh there
has been accusations between the two
sides there's also the issue of uh of
who will lead the sovereignty council
and that is the crucial issue now as per
the constitutional declaration the army
is supposed to hold power for 21 months
and then had it over to civilians for 18
months but a peace agreement signed in
october 2020 uh between the armed groups
and the transitional council reset the
clock of that transition and it's not
clear yet what is what what what what
the civilians and the military are to do
out to make of the 14 months that pass
prior to the finding of the agreement
now there has been no agreement there's
been no written uh uh clarification on
whether they will divide it between
themselves the one that has been passed
and and the additional ones will be
split between the military disabilities
and that has created a lot of tension
with the military saying we still have
21 months
the original time for the transition
started in october 2020 when a peace
agreement was signed and with the
civilians saying no we have 14 months
that passed with you guys in power and
as per the constitutional declaration
you guys are not supposed to be leading
for more than 21 months even with the
extension
i didn't give you uh more than
additional six or seven months let me
just jump in here with a final thought
because we're just seeing uh some wire
copy here that sudan's information
ministry says the military has arrested
uh government figures uh government
ministers and their whereabouts remain
unknown so the first response there from
uh sudan's information ministry
that leads me to another question heber
and if you can just be brief i mean it's
interesting that only some members of
the cabinet have been detained what's
that telling us about why the military
has chosen to cherry-pick who it detains
now if you look at the pro-military
group and what they've been saying
they've been saying that specific
political parties have been taking over
this transition they say that many of
them uh that more than 30 people
participate in the revolution but only
four political parties get a bigger
representation than the rest of the
parties now when you look at the head of
the spokesperson of the sovereignty
council and the minister of information
they come from the same party that's the
democratic democratic unionist party and
when you look at the cabinet defense
minister and the
minister of industry they also come from
the same political party which is the
sudanese congress party so it looks like
they're targeting specific parties in
this um in this cabinet and not everyone
because a lot of the cameras ministers
uh are yet we get to hear news of their
arrests it looks like they so far have
uh basically stayed out of the line of
fire for lack of better words but uh so
far we have confirmed that there's
several government officials that have
been arrested
and if this is not a coup then the fact
that the internet has been restricted
the fact that phones have been
restricted uh the fact that the airport
and bridges uh shut off does not uh show
good signs and which is why we're seeing
protesters stick to the streets they're
saying that again the military is going
against the constitutional declaration
on how to shape this transitional
government all right morgan bringing us
an update there
from khartoum uh heber thank you so
let's just examine how did sudan get to
this point well in december 2018
thousands of people in the northeastern
region of athbar protested against high
unemployment poverty and corruption
within days those protests spread to
other cities including the capital
khartoum in april 2019 the military
moved president omar al-bashir from
office after nearly 30 years in power
but four months later and after
accusations of excessive use of force
against protesters the military agreed
to form a civilian-led transitional
government the new cabinet took office
in september under prime minister
abdullah hamdok as part of a three-year
power sharing agreement uh so let's
bring in again hollywood care she's a
managing partner at insight strategy
partners that's a public affairs firm
based in seattle and they specialize in
government relations and khalid has been
on the phone with us throughout the
morning from sudan's capital cartoon uh
so we may not be calling this a coup
just yet but it does have the makings
doesn't it of a full military takeover
absolutely i mean the closing of the
bridges the um the closing down of
telecoms uh there's a complete um
[Music]
internet blackout you can't make phone
calls you can't send text to sms
messages um
quite clearly the arrests of key
government figures including um members
of the sovereign council and also the
minister for cabinet affairs khalid
ahmed indicate very much that this is a
coup in in any case any contravention of
the constitutional declaration or the
constitutional document of 2019
um and and any sort of push by the
military to try and maneuver certain
civilian actors is considered a coup by
the constitutional declaration which is
why we're seeing protests start to come
out um
in the streets of cartoon as of this
morning and we saw that wire drop that
sudan's uh information ministry uh had
responded to events by saying that yes
indeed the military has arrested
government figures and ministers um
although we also don't know their
whereabouts and also the prime minister
abdullah
how significant is this that the
military has now responded and
officially come out and said yes there
have been these military arrests
the interesting thing is that we haven't
actually heard a sin from the military
um for a few days now certainly since
the the mass protest and the mass
turnout on the 21st of october i i think
that the military was
surprised by to the extent to which
there was anti-military sentiment within
the country and the extent to which
people across the country not just in
cartoons came out against military rule
um by comparison to the the crowd seeing
um the massive crowd scene on the 21st
their sort of sponsored or brokered or
orchestrated protest a week earlier so
much fewer people probably in the
thousands but dwindle then to only
probably a hundred or even fewer um
the interesting thing about the the
media angle is that in the past 48 hours
we've seen the sudan news agency
building stormed by pro-ministry
supporters last night we heard
that the ministry of information was
also stormed and it's quite clear that
the gov that the military wants to get
ahead of this narrative um probably
because of things that they it does
still have some civilian support um but
again that support is not by any means
um the majority of sydney people based
on the number of protests um
you mentioned this anti-military
sentiment that we we just heard from the
sudanese communist party uh who are now
calling for civil disobedience how are
those calls likely then to play out on
the streets do you think
well civil disobedience is is very
effective in sudan is that in that a lot
of people do tend to conform to it it's
been a very protect uh a very um sort of
constructive means of climbing pressure
um because it applies to both the formal
and the informal sector um and
in in addition to protests which of
course have
are sort of a great sign
of discontent but they're not
necessarily always constructed
and in the way that they uh impact
decision-makers of the way they impact
the military with a
civil disobedience you get much more of
that targeted
impact on the economy and we know of
course with the military that the
economy is very important the the
military maintains and has maintained
throughout the transition period uh as a
sort of a death grip if you will on the
economy and has been nose to give up all
its um interest in state-owned
enterprises and also private enterprises
that it got during um bashir's time in
power and so this should have at least
send a very clear signal again
uh to the military that there is a very
strong opposition to their takeover or
any attempt of a takeover just a final
thought to you um i mean in terms of the
broader sudanese political landscape and
one analyst we were talking to earlier
on described uh this uh these developing
events as the beginning of the end of
the democratic experiment in sudan is
that how you see it because when we were
talking to you earlier you you talked
about the transitional government being
a big pretense
the transitional the the partnership
between the different very very sort of
different uh interest within the
civilian gov the transitional government
was a theater if you will but i wouldn't
say that this is the end of the
democratic experiment in sudan that's a
very a historical outlook i would say
that it's the end of the civil military
partnership or that that experiment that
we have now but that sort of been um the
case pretty much since june um since the
prime minister has come out to say that
the ministry does need your reform and
it does need to push through
all the different um issues that were
stuck at the sovereign council and that
it needed to let go of its controlling
share of a lot of um economic interests
so that experiment is done now i think
um the gloves have been off for a while
certainly since the attempted coup of
september 21st but if um if people
coming out in the streets today and
civil disobedience is not also democracy
then i don't know what is certainly
we're going to see a lot more of that
all right
they're updating us on the phone from
sudan's capital cartoon hollywood thank
you for that let me just wrap up for you
if you're just joining if you're just
tuning in to al jazeera here the
pictures you're seeing in your screen uh
of protests on the streets of the
sudanese capital cartoon uh following
news uh that the military has arrested
several uh high-profile civilian
ministers and officials including we
understand the prime minister abdullah
hamdok now protest leaders in response
have been calling on people to take to
the streets and those are some of the
pictures you're seeing on your screens
and resist what they say could be a
military coup and we know that tension
has been rising for weeks between the
military and civilian factions within uh
the power sharing government which has
been a very fragile transition
government so of course more on this
developing story as we get it here on al
jazeera